getting back back again grace back
please god damn it tell your friends no
you know it's different now on Tuesday I
put up a video where I tried to recreate
Taco Bell chicken quesadillas in my
research process for looking up Taco
Bell menu recipes the number one thing
that came up was a Crunchwrap
Bob all the ingredients for it in case
the chicken quesadilla is wet bad
chicken quesadillas went cliff hanger if
you want to find out go watch my last
video and then I have all the
ingredients last week I ended up making
Crunchwrap Supremes and it turned out
kind of okay Taco Bell is basically just
like a salt mush trough with some crunch
occasionally so I thought let's just
roll with the momentum and make another
Taco Bell menu item this week I got this
recipe from delish calm I'll put the
link in the description box below let's
make this Crunchwrap supreme shall we
you have no choice we're doing it I'm
feeling confident about this - do you
know someone's really confident when
they struggle that's the word so in a
skillet over medium heat we're gonna add
some ground beef some chili powder some
paprika and some cumin we're gonna cook
it they say like five minutes then we're
gonna drain all the fat oils out of it
and add some salt and pepper so now we
need flour tortillas and tostadas which
are basically just flat crunchy tortilla
I was supposed to get large flour
tortillas but I think I got like a
medium-sized I probably should have got
a bigger size so you're supposed to take
your tostada put it on top of your
tortilla and cut around their idea and a
tostada put those to the side then we're
gonna build on Crunchwrap so we're gonna
tickle
another large flour tortilla lay it down
a scoop of the ground beef this is where
I go wrong and always overpack it leave
a generous space around the edge because
that's what you're gonna fold up I don't
make sure my
Hana's on slightly hop with some oil
they were to take our cheese stop put
some drizzles of that on you perfect
there we go then we put the tostada
shell on top I'm gonna clip it around
the edges a little bit do a quick
haircut then write about sour cream on
top of this why do they make food that's
bad for you like so gross to open oh so
you think about it sour cream okay they
put lettuce I didn't have lettuce but I
had cabbage in my refrigerator so we're
using cabbage everything's a little bit
gonna be bad tomatoes they just put some
shredded cheddar and some shredded
Monterey Jack cheese on I have cheddar
Jack and Mexican style cheese it's all a
slop trough and nothing's better than
anything else so what's gonna happen now
and this is the part I'm so bad at and
trying to practice the cut out that we
did of the tostada shape we're gonna put
on top and then we're gonna slowly start
to fold our bottom tortilla around and
then we're just gonna try and shove it
in the pan as fast as we can so it
doesn't fall but you know guess what
it's gonna fall apart
all right they make it look so easy in
their video I highly encourage you to
watch it get we folded it enough here we
go oh we push this up so hard going to
fold it oh oh when I fell apart
immediately why did I even try to do
this beforehand you wanna see this look
this is the saddest Crunchwrap supreme
i'm so sad and for some weird reason it
smells like fish i don't know why so
you're supposed to cook it seems side
down for three to five minutes and then
turn it over and cook it another three
to five minutes i'm gonna try to make
another one to redeem myself
my children you're all the Crunchwrap
supreme so that made because couldn't
stop I've made three of them see my
first 10 the second attempt and my third
attempt which I'm honestly super proud
of because I think it looks the most
like Crunchwrap supreme but the sad part
is that it takes Taco Bell like I don't
know 45 seconds to make this thing and
this took me about an hour and a half
let's see if it tastes the same Tom do
you see this little thing it's literally
like she knows the one place that she
can sit ok sorry I found you huh the one
place that she can sit in the corner
when she's in frame and it's like she
reads your comments and gets your
sympathy Cheers
yeah yeah it's just a salt drop I
thought is it mixed delicious just one
more for good measure yeah thank you
delish I don't know what the moral is
here getting Taco Bell is so easy to do
making it at home
way harder it gives you way more time to
think through like what you're doing so
if you want to live that kalle don't
forget to subscribe to my youtube
channel can I write it consistently
inconsistent so hit that Bell
notification so you know when I post
videos because I don't even know I don't
know I'm just gonna eat it cuz that's
how you eat talk about you don't
question the formality and you don't
question the what emotional state led
you here you also definitely don't
question the emotional state that led
you to create your own Taco Bell at home
that's my bug zapper Oh
all of these are sad sentences that I'm
saying